but if the Earth stopped on a dime would
you fly right off the surface
if the planet came to an abrupt halt the
atmosphere would still be in motion
that means though everything has lurched
to a stop powerful winds would continue
to blow and these wouldn't be a strong
Breeze
they would be many times stronger than
any storm you've ever encountered
those winds would knock you off your
feet these winds would be strong enough
to tear up the Earth's crust these winds
would obliterate you the winds from the
Earth's emergency brake would be three
times stronger than that so if the crust
under your feet didn't crumble you and a
lot of other stuff would likely go
flying a great distance